aussi si le gouvernement n'a pas de
majorité c'est pas le fruit du hasard
c'est pas le fruit d'une erreur des
Français qui aurait mal voté mais d'une
volonté des Français d'obliger la
majorité de Biger le gouvernement à
écouter l'ensemble des formations
politiques qui les représentent et donc
évidemment
nous demandons au gouvernement c'est le
premier 49-3 mais il y en aura d'autres
durant le temps que durera ce
quinquennat il y en aura sans doute 5 6
d'ici la fin de d'ici la fin de de la
session d'ici Noël et donc demandons au
gouvernement évidemment de retenir un
maximum des propositions qui ont été
faites par les différents groupes
d'opposition